[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW SOLOMON: Thank you.
Thank you all for coming.
I was assigned about 20 years
ago to write a piece on deaf
politics for "The New York Times
Magazine." And when I
got the assignment, I was a
little bewildered by it
because I had mostly been doing
foreign reporting, and I
wasn't at all clear on why I
was given this particular
assignment.
And my editor said to me,
you've been very good at
penetrating foreign cultures,
and I think this is a foreign
culture within our
own society.
And at the time, I thought that
deafness was simply a
disability.
It was a misfortune.
Those poor people, wouldn't it
be great if we could get them
all hearing?
And I was very surprised because
I worked in the deaf
world to find the robust nature
of the deaf political
movement and the deaf
cultural movement.
I met deaf people who were
members of deaf clubs.
I saw the deaf theatre.
I saw deaf poetry.
And I saw what an intimacy there
was among people united
by the common use of
sign language.
And I came to understand
deafness as a culture.
It wasn't my culture, and I
didn't particularly want to
lose my hearing and go to join
it, but I recognized that it
was a very valid culture for
all of the people who were
part of it.
And then after I had that basic
experience, I discovered
that most deaf people are
born to hearing parents.
That they mostly are brought up
by parents who really want
them to function in
the hearing world.
That many of them discover the
deaf culture when they get
into their adolescence or at
some point thereafter.
And when they discover it, it
comes as a great liberation.
And then their parents have to
reckon with the fact that
their children belong
to a culture
that's foreign to them.
And some parents deal with it
well, and some parents deal
with it very badly.
So as I began examining that
set of questions, I thought
they had a lot of resonance
for me because I had the
experience of being gay.
And most gay people are born
to straight parents.
And those parents by and large,
at some level, at least
traditionally, have tried to get
their children to conform
to what they see as the norms
of the normal world either
because those parents are
embarrassed by who their
children are, or simply because
they think that this
life in some other culture
looks foreign, and
frightening, and disorienting.
And they think that it's a
harder life and possibly an
unhappier one.
And so I saw this parallel,
and I wrote when I did the
piece for "The Times Magazine"
about the similarities between
deaf politics and culture and
gay politics and culture.
And while, as I've said deafness
is not my culture, it
seemed to me to have much of the
vitality that was familiar
to me from gay culture.
And then about 10 years went by
and a friend of a friend of
mine had a daughter
who was a dwarf.
And I saw her one night, and she
started talking about the
questions she was facing.
Should she bring her daughter up
to think she was just like
everyone else but a little
short, or should she bring up
her daughter with a sense of
difference and a sense of
pride in that difference.
Should she get involved in the
Little People of America.
What were the things that she
should do in order to ensure
that her child grow
up healthy.
And as she talked about it and
as I found out that most
dwarfs are born to parents of
average height, I thought,
this is a recurring thing in
which you have a family the
perceives itself at some level
or another to be normal.
And they have a kid whom they
perceive at some level or
other to be alien.
And they have to figure
out what to do
with this alien child.
And eventually, I formulated
the idea that there are two
kinds of identities.
There's vertical identity
and horizontal identity.
And vertical identity it is the
word I use for any kind of
identity that's passed
down generationally.
So one's ethnicity is usually
a vertical identity.
It's something you have in
common with your parents.
Your nationality, often your
religion, your language, these
are all things you have in
common with your parents.
And there's very little attempt
made to redress
vertical identity.
So arguments can be made that
belonging to an ethnic
minority, even in the United
States as it's constructed
today, carries with it
difficulties and burdens but
nobody is trying to prevent
members of the minority from
being born and being part
of their ethnic group.
You can argue I don't know, for
example, there's a lot of
anti-Semitism.
It could be difficult
to be Jewish in
certain sectors of America.
But no one has sort of started
a campaign on how to make
sure, at least not since it
rather tragically happened a
long time ago, to make sure
that Jews are not born to
Jewish parents.
But any kind of identity which
is what I've called
horizontal--
where the child has a quality
that's expressly different
from the parents and has to come
to a feeling of identity
about that quality-- that
feeling of identity is learned
as I've said horizontally
from a peer group.
It's learned from other
people you meet
outside of the family.
And those identities
consistently people are trying
to fix, and to change,
and to address.
And so I set out to look at
what is the range of these
horizontal identities.
I looked at my own experience
as a gay person.
I looked at deafness, dwarfism,
Down syndrome,
autism, schizophrenia.
I looked at multiple severe
disabilities and the way that
people respond to those.
At families who had kids who
were prodigies because the
point I wanted to make is that
it's difference that's
difficult rather than whether
the valence of that difference
is positive or negative.
Most prodigies are born to
parents who don't have any
particular genius in the field
that the children operate in.
I looked at families bringing up
children conceived in rape
in order to demonstrate that the
sense of the child being
somehow alien and different
could have to do not only with
what the child inherently
was but also where
the child came from.
I had families of kids who
commit crimes, who have their
image of their child destroyed
by something that the child
does and then have to reckon
with that difference.
And then a chapter on families
of people who are transgender.
And I framed the whole thing
with my experience as the gay
child with straight parents
at the beginning and my
experience of becoming a parent
myself at the end.
So that's the sort of narrative
structure that I
worked with.
And it took a long while to
penetrate all of these
communities.
I ended up interviewing about
300 families over 11 years.
It's different understanding
the genetics of autism, and
understanding the problems of
the criminal justice system,
and understanding what
constitutes musical genius,
for example.
So I was very much in the thick
of all of those studies.
What I found is, I looked at
all of these categories was
that each of them
individually, is quite isolating.
There are only so many
families dealing with
schizophrenia.
There are only so many families
who have kids who
have committed crimes.
There are only so many families
who are dealing with
children who have got multiple
really severe disabilities.
But that actually the experience
of dealing with a
child who's somewhat different
from you is almost a universal
experience.
And that every family I talked
to described things that were
in common with the other
families I talked to.
And I thought if you think of
yourself as having something
in common only with other
families dealing with autism,
you're in a little segment
of the population.
If you think of yourself as
having something in common
with families who are
negotiating difference, then
suddenly you find that
you're in the
mainstream in many ways.
And I've yet to meet any parent
who hasn't occasionally
looked at their child and
thought, where on earth did
you come from?
And I found as I got deeper and
deeper into the experience
of writing about all of these
families, that there was a
parallel between their more
extreme experience and
everyone else's experience.
So the same way that you might
test children's pajamas by
putting them in an inferno to
make sure that the sleeve
doesn't catch fire if your child
reaches across a stove.
So in that same way by looking
at these extreme circumstances
and this extreme negotiation of
difference, you really are
looking at what the universal
experience of parenting is.
So that was sort of where
I started out.
And then I got very deep into
these communities and tried to
look at the enormous prejudice
people experience, at the
shape and nature of that
experience, and at how people
are able to transcend it.
And I think that we forget to
some degree how much our
perception of all of these
differences has changed over
the last 30 or 40 years.
And I thought to myself, each
of these things can be
experienced as an illness,
and each of them can be
experienced as an identity.
Indeed, almost anything can be
experienced as an illness or
as an identity.
You can experience being very
young or very old as an
illness in some ways.
There are context in which
it will make it
harder for you to function.
You can experience any of these
things as who you are in
central to your identity.
And I thought the tension
between the illness model and
the identity model
is very strong.
And I felt especially well
qualified to talk about it
because when I was growing
up, I experienced
gayness as an illness.
And in my adult life, it's very
definitely an identity.
And when I was experiencing it
as an illness, almost everyone
experienced it as an illness.
And now a lot of people are
experiencing it as an identity.
And I thought, OK, how did we
get from there to here?
So I'm going to read to you just
a few little excerpts in
the book of things that
people have said.
But this was written when
I was a child in "Time
Magazine," which was considered
a relatively
liberal voice of the American
establishment.
"Even in purely non-religious
terms, homosexuality
represents a misuse of
the sexual faculty.
It is a pathetic little
second-rate substitute for
reality, a pitiable
flight from life.
As such, it deserves no
encouragement, no
glamorization, no
rationalization, no fake
status as minority martyrdom,
no sophistry about simple
differences in taste, and above
all, no pretense that it
is anything but a pernicious
sickness."
So the fact that we could in
about 40-some years, get from
that to having a president who
has come out in support of gay
marriage, is little short
of astonishing.
And I was very interested
in how that
shift had taken place.
I'm gonna read to you-- just for
purposes of parallelism,
because sometimes I mean, the
gay movement has been more
visible than some others--
a passage from about the same
time by an ethicist named
Joseph Fletcher who was writing
in "The Atlantic,"
which was an even more
liberal paper.
And he's writing about kids
with Down syndrome.
He said, "There is no reason to
feel guilty about putting a
Down syndrome baby away, whether
it's put away in the
sense of hidden in a sanatorium
or in a more
responsible lethal sense.
It is sad, yes, dreadful,
but it carries no guilt.
True guilt arises only from an
offense against a person and a
Downs is not a person."
So that was 1968.
So I was very interested in
where the shift came from and
what the shift has
looked like.
And I also became interested in
the tension that frequently
exists between social
movements, which are
liberalizing and have
essentially said, we should
recognize and respect and
value difference and the
medical movements that exist
that say, these differences
are difficult and can we
cure and resolve them.
So in writing about the deaf, I
ran into the question of the
cochlear implant.
The cochlear implant is a
medical device surgically
implanted in the brain which
create some sort of facsimile
of hearing, bypassing the
cochlear which is often
damaged in people who
have deafness.
Most people who have
deafness have some
form of cochlear deafness.
So it was greeted by many
people as this glorious
resolution to a terrible
problem.
And it was greeted by many
people within the deaf
community as a terrible affront
in which they felt
that the implant was
erasing deafness.
That it was genocidal.
That it was going to wipe
out the deaf community.
And I found myself feeling
very torn about that.
Because at the individual
level, I do think
it's hard to be deaf.
And at the individual level, I
think if you can save someone
from that difficulty and enable
them to have full
communication, especially with
their parents because being
able to communicate with your
parents is a cornerstone of
early mental health, which is
a cornerstone of lifetime
mental health, I thought
that's very valuable.
At the same time, having spent
time in the deaf community, I
thought the disappearance of
it on the face of the earth
would be a terrible loss.
And I felt as though the social
acceptance of deafness
as a culture has really reached
its apex just as this
medical ability effectively to
eliminate much of deafness
from the world has
reached its apex.
And I sometime said, it was like
one of those operas in
which the hero realizes he loves
the heroine at the exact
moment when she expires
on a sofa.
So that was kind of a
persistent thing.
And I also thought, what does it
mean for parents to accept
what their child is like?
What does it mean for parents
to change what
their child is like?
What does it mean for parents
to have to decide what to
accept and what to attempt
to change?
And I wrote a little bit about
my early experience.
I have dyslexia.
My mom picked up my dyslexia
very early on.
She worked with me endlessly
on reading when I
was a little kid.
And while I'm still dyslexic,
we found lots of ways to
compensate for it, and reading
and writing turned out not to
be my problem in life.
But I think her sense that we
could trounce that obvious
neurological abnormality led her
then, when I was older, to
think that really we could deal
with this thing of my
being gay, and get
it to go away.
And I always remember and have
written about the time that my
mother and my brother and
I were at a shoe store.
And when we were leaving, the
salesman asked us whether we
would like a balloon.
And my brother wanted
a red balloon.
And I said that I wanted
a pink balloon.
And my mother said
that actually I
wanted a blue balloon.
And I said, no, I really wanted
the pink balloon.
And she reminded me that my
favorite color was blue.
And the fact that now my
favorite color is blue and I'm
still gay is evidence, I
think, of my mother's
influence and its limits.
So what is it that happens when
you're trying to change
your child?
What are the things that's
appropriate to change?
appropriate to accept?
Those questions run all the
way through the work.
And I found as I started working
on this, that there
are people in many communities
where I would have thought
that amelioration of some
condition was the appropriate
step who actually felt very
strongly that they wanted to
stay as exactly who they were.
So the autism rights movement,
which is very vibrant and very
much alive, in which people who
have got various forms of
autism talk about how
it's their identity
and who they are.
How does that line up the kids
were banging their head
against a wall in the corner
and don't have any speech?
How do you reconcile the full
spectrum of autism?
These are complicated
questions.
But this is what one of the
autism activists said.
"When parents say, 'I wish my
child did not have autism.'
What they're really saying is,
'I wish the autistic child I
have did not exist and I had a
different, non-autistic child
instead.'
Read that again.
This is what we hear when you
mourn over our existence.
This is what we hear when
you pray for a cure.
This is what we know when you
tell us of your fondest hopes
and dreams for us, that your
greatest wish is that one day
we will cease to be and
strangers you can love will
move in behind our faces."
That's from Jim Sinclair
who has autism.
One of the questions that comes
up over and over again
in considering any of these
issues is what constitutes a
disability, what constitutes a
difference, and what the sort
of upside can be to various
kinds of difference.
So one of the people
I interviewed is
a guy and his family.
He was born with diastrophic
dwarfism.
And the doctors at the hospital
said to his mother
that he was never going to learn
to walk or to talk, that
they were never going to have
any kind of relationship with
him, and that they really
probably should just leave him
at the hospital, and hospital
would take care of
him until he died.
And his mother decided that she
was not going to do that--
and his father, the two
of them together--
and they brought him home.
And his mother then did
a lot of research.
This was pre-internet for
most people at least.
It was the mid '80s, and his
mother was doing research to
try to find the best doctor
to treat him.
She herself worked as an
operator in a call center.
His father was a construction
worker.
They didn't have huge resources
or tremendous education.
But his mother some how found
the best doctor for dealing
with kids with his condition was
someone at Johns Hopkins.
In the course of the first 10
years of his life, he had 30
surgical interventions as a
result of which he is in fact
able to walk.
While he was stuck in the
hospital for these long
periods of time, he had
nothing else to do.
So when the tutors came around
to teach him, he ended up
actually doing a lot of school
work, turned out to be
extremely bright, was the first
person in his family
ever to go to college.
And his mother told me one day
we were talking on the phone
and she said, oh, I
had such a day.
She said, I was out.
Clinton drives this
special car with
all of these fittings.
I was driving home, and I saw
it was parked, she said,
outside a bar.
And I thought to myself,
oh, my god.
He's in the bar.
His friends are six feet tall.
He's three feet tall.
Two beers for them is
four beers for him.
She said, I just thought,
is he going to be OK?
Is he going to make
it back home?
I couldn't go in there.
I went home.
I left him a bunch of messages
on his answering machine.
She said, and then I suddenly
thought, if someone had said
to me when he was born that my
worry was that he would go
drinking and driving with his
college buddies, I would have
been so thrilled to
have that problem.
And this is a little
quote from her.
I said to her, because he's a
remarkable and very charming
fellow, I said to her, what do
you think you did that helped
him to have such a good and
successful life and to be such
an amazing guy?
And his mother said,
"What did I do?
I loved him, that's all.
The other day, these people
much higher up than us
socially, much more educated
called me up and said, they
couldn't handle this.
They were in Texas politics and
thought the stigma would
be harmful to them.
And they gave their baby
up for adoption.
That's just what they were
going to do, and it's the
opposite of what I
was going to do
right from the beginning.
The other day, Clinton came home
and he goes, 'Ma, I saw a
blind man today with a
stick in Manhattan.
There were people rushing
back and forth,
and he was all alone.
I just felt like crying.
I felt so sorry for him.
So I offered to bring him to
where he needed to go.'
Clinton just always had that
light in him, and we were
lucky enough to be the first
to see it there."
And I felt that model of
parental love was one that I
ran into over and over again.
That sense of parents who
managed truly to see children
who by some standards would have
been considered difficult
to see, difficult to sympathize
with, difficult to
understand.
And I found that there was
always the question of why
some families were able to
derive a positive version of
these experiences
and others not.
And I increasingly saw it as
something that people could
construct for themselves.
So I interviewed a family, Tom
and Karen Robards, who live
here on the Upper West
Side about their son
who has Down syndrome.
And they were hard-charging,
Wall Street types.
At some point, they decided
that they were
going to have kids.
When their son was born with
Down syndrome, they looked at
the educational things that
were available to him, and
they decided that none of them
was really very good.
They started a tiny little
center to help kids.
It was in two rooms which were
converted lavatories here in
New York that they somehow
got from the
Archdiocese of the city.
They've been involved
in Catholic causes.
And they ended up getting very
involved in building the Cooke
Center, which now serves
hundreds and hundreds of
children and helped to set up
the educational principles,
which have allowed people with
Down syndrome to function at a
level that was completely
unimaginable
30 or 40 years ago.
People with Down syndrome
live three times as long
as they used to.
They're on TV.
They're able to live
on their own.
The progress with Down syndrome
has being huge at the
exact same time that the
progress with prenatal
screening has been huge, and
the numbers of people being
born with Down syndrome
have come down.
But I said to them, look, this
has been such a gigantic part
of your life.
You've worked so hard on it.
I said, do you regret it?
Do you wish that your child
didn't have Down syndrome?
Do you wish that you weren't
doing this whole thing that
you're doing?
Would you like to
make it go away?
And his dad said, you know, for
my son, I would like to be
able to make it go away.
For the world, I think if we
didn't have people with Down
syndrome, it would
be a real loss.
And his mother said, you know,
I'm with my husband.
For my son, I would make it go
away because it's a difficult
way to be in the world, and
I'd like to give him the
easiest possible life.
But speaking for myself, while
I would have never have
believed 23 years ago when he
was born that I could come to
such a point, speaking for
myself, it's made us better
people than we would have been
without it and given us a
richer and more interesting
life.
And speaking for myself, I
wouldn't give it up for
anything in the world.
That motif of people saying I
have this child looks aberrant
and whom one would think I would
want not to have, and I
nonetheless have found enormous
meaning in it, was recurrent.
And I found at some point
that I kept thinking,
yeah, but come on.
I mean, really, if you had the
option, you wouldn't have a
child like this.
You wouldn't have this life.
You'd have some other life.
And ultimately I thought it
doesn't really matter what
someone would have chosen if
they had had a choice they
didn't have.
What matters is whether they've
managed to construct
the feeling of value
in their own life.
And the more that they're able
to do that, the more likely it
is that they're actually going
to be able to take care of
their children adequately and
find joy and pleasure
in their own lives.
And a lot of the parents, as
it turned out, actually
recognized the degree
to which this was a
manufactured business.
So I had one mother who had two
children with very, very
severe disabilities.
She had one.
She was told it was an absolute
anomaly and she
should go ahead and have
more children.
They were told that.
They had a child, a second child
who was born with all of
these disabilities.
And eventually, the children,
who are very difficult to take
care of and had to be lifted
in and out of bed in the
bathtub, the mother
herniated a disc.
The father was finding it very
difficult to schedule things.
They put them in a group home,
which they visited every day
but where there were
professionals who could deal
with those things.
One of those professionals
left one of the children
unattended in a bathtub and he
slipped down and drowned.
And when I talk to them about
it, his mother described the
enormous pain she felt.
And when she buried his ashes,
she gave this extraordinary
sermon and she said, "Let me
bury here the rage I feel to
have been twice robbed, once of
the child I wanted and once
of the son I loved."
One of the other people who also
had ended up-- it happens
more than you would think--
with two children who had very
severe disabilities, I was
talking to her about the ways
in which she and her husband
had found meaning in things.
And she said, "I actually think
it's not believing in
God that has given us
this perspective.
People always regale us with
these little sayings like,
'God doesn't give you any more
than you can handle.' But
children like ours are not
preordained as a gift.
They're a gift because that's
what we have chosen."
Well, to choose that about a
child with severe disabilities
is one thing.
To choose it about a child who
has some of these other
extraordinary qualities
is something else.
And so I went and talked to
these many women dealing with
children conceived in rape,
many of whom were deeply
traumatized and in enormous
pain about it.
And there was one of them
to whom I said--
I was in Rwanda where I went
to interview people who had
been raped in the genocide
because there were so many of
them bringing up children
from that period.
And there was one woman I met
who said to me, told me her
story, I mean her horrific
story of what
she had been through.
And at the end of interviews,
especially when I'm out of my
own context, I tend to say to
people, do you have any
questions for me.
Because it helps to redress the
sort of power imbalance of
the interview situation.
And in Rwanda, people had
said, will this be
published in French?
Are you going to use my name?
How long are you staying here?
Those were the kinds
of questions I got.
And I interviewed this one woman
who said to me when I
asked her that, she said, well,
you work in this field
of psychology, right?
And I said, well,
yes, sort of.
And she said, can you tell me
how to love my daughter more?
Because I want to love her so
much, but when I look at her,
I think about the terrible
things that happened and it
gets in the way.
And I was so taken aback by the
question, I just sort of
stood there, and she repeated in
this very insistent voice.
And she had tears running
down her face.
She said, can you tell me how
to love my daughter more?
And it was only a week
afterwards as I kept thinking
about it that I thought how much
love there was in that
question itself.
In talking to families of people
who committed crimes, I
looked at the ways in which
people have to struggle with
what their children have done
and especially with the injury
their children have
caused to others.
And one of the families I
interviewed was the family of
Dylan Klebold who was one of
the perpetrators of the
Columbine massacre.
And Tom and Sue Klebold were
initially very resistant to
the idea being interviewed.
It was a long dance
of seduction to
draw them into it.
Finally, we got to the point
at which they were ready to
talk to me.
The first weekend that we spent
together, having said
that they weren't sure they
were going to talk at all,
they couldn't stop.
They were so full
of their story.
And at the end of three days in
which we recorded more than
20 hours of interviews, we
were all sitting at the
kitchen table.
And I said, well, if Dylan were
here now, do have a sense
of what you'd want to ask him or
what you want to tell him?
And his father said,
I sure do.
I'd want to ask him what the
hell he thought he was doing.
And his mother kind of looked at
the floor, and she thought
for a minute.
And she looked back up and she
said, I would ask him to
forgive me for being his mother
and never knowing what
was going on inside his head.
And afterwards, several years
afterwards, she and I had
dinner together.
And she said to me, "You know,
when it first happened, I used
to wish that I had never
had children,
that I had never married.
If Tom and I hadn't crossed
paths at Ohio State, Dylan
wouldn't have existed, and this
terrible thing wouldn't
have happened.
But over time, I've come to feel
that, for myself, I am
glad I had kids and glad
I had the kids I did.
Because the love for them,
even at the price of this
pain, has been the single
greatest joy of my life.
When I say that, I'm speaking of
my own pain and not of the
pain of other people.
But I accept my own pain.
Life is full of suffering,
and this is mine.
I know it would have been better
for the world if Dylan
had never been born.
But I believe it would not
have been better for me."
The final chapter as I mentioned
is about people who
are transgender, and that was a
world in which I spent a lot
of time, and in which I had
a lot of very, very moving
experiences.
And one of the people I got to
know is a transwoman named Kim
Reed, who, when she was a boy,
was the quarterback on her
high school football team.
And she eventually made a film,
which was about going to
her 20th high school reunion
and what it was like coming
back to Montana having
made this change.
And my particular favorite
moment in the film is when
she's at the reunion and she's
talking to somebody else from
her class who says, "But Kim,
we've all changed." But Kim
was eventually invited to do a
weekend at her church in which
she gave the sermon.
And she was also invited to show
the film at her church.
And the church had a whole day
in which people could have
seminars to discuss the issues
that it brought up.
And I want to just
read you a little
excerpt from that sermon.
I was there in Montana for
the weekend in question.
The sermon was quite amazing.
She said, "The night before last
when our film was playing
in here, I went outside to the
columbarium where my father's
ashes rest.
As I was kneeling there by
what I call Dad's spot, I
thought of the hours and hours
of videotape that he shot
lovingly of me during my
football games and how much of
the same footage was now being
shown inside this sanctuary.
Now, it's certainly not the
context that any of us
expected, but I knew
dad would be proud.
And just then, the dusk breeze
blew in this waft of sound,
and it was strangely
familiar to me.
And I realized it was the
crosstown football game coming
from the stadium.
The band was playing, and the
announcer was bellowing, and
all of these old tapes
were playing
inside here on the screen.
And I knew that new ones were
being recorded just a few
blocks away.
Those recording their new
memories to tape should be
only so lucky as to be surprised
by the last thing
that they expected from their
loved ones, only so fortunate
as to get a chance to welcome
them home with radical love.
I thought about how all
these cycles of lives
would continue on.
And so many aspects of my life
coalesced in that one moment,
that one beautiful, stunning,
blessed moment, the past and
the present, parent and child,
male and female, the pain that
life sometimes brings, and the
soothing love that welcomes it
with open arms after its
exhausting journey into a
distant country."
And when that afternoon I said
to Kim's mom, Carol, I said,
do you wish things
were different?
Do you wish that Paul had been
happy to be Paul and hadn't
had to change to be Kim?
She said, "Well,
of course I do.
It would have been easier for
Paul and for the rest of us.
But the key phrase in there is
'happy to be Paul.' He wasn't.
And I'm just so glad that
he had the courage to do
something about it.
I had someone say this weekend,
'Carol, Paul died,
and I haven't finished
mourning that.'
I don't feel that.
Kim is much more present to
people than Paul ever was.
Paul was never rude.
He just wasn't totally
present.
We didn't quite have his
attention, and look what we
got, Kim."
It's a book about familial
acceptance.
And it's easy in the course of
telling these few stories that
I've pulled for a talk here
today, to lose sight of the
fact that actually
many families
reject their children.
That about half of transgender
children are rejected by their
families of origin.
That many people in all of these
situations are rejected,
are put up for adoption,
are sent away.
That however, isn't news, and
it isn't particularly
surprising.
I tried to talk about
it in the book.
I looked at, for example, how
frequently parents of children
with autism end up committing
filicide and killing their own
children because they find life
with them so unbearable.
It's not happening in most
cases, but it's happening more
frequently than you think.
But I really wanted to look
at what this process is of
constructing meaning and what
the process is of allowing
your child to emerge in their
full independence.
And I feel it profoundly
informed my decision to become
a parent myself.
So many people said to me, I
can't believe you decided to
have a family right in the
middle of a book about
everything that could
go wrong.
And what I've said over and over
again is, it's not a book
about everything that can go
wrong, it's a book about the
resilience and power of parental
love even when
everything goes wrong.
So I married my husband
in 2007, originally.
And when I met him almost 12
years ago, he was already the
biological father of his son
with some lesbian friends in
Minneapolis.
He had said he would be involved
in that son's life to
the extent that the son
and his moms wanted.
But for the time being, he was
very disengaged to ensure that
the two mothers were
recognized as
his son's two parents.
A few years later, they asked
him to be the donor again.
And so Oliver was the first
child and Lucy was the second.
In the meanwhile, one of my
closest friends from college
had gone through a divorce.
And I said to her, oh,
are you feeling
sad about being divorced?
And she said, I'm actually glad
to be out of a marriage
that had become very painful,
but I'm sad
about not having kids.
And I said in a rather jocular
way, I said, well, if you ever
decide you want to have
kids, I think you'd
be an amazing mother.
And I've always wanted
kids, and I'd be
glad to be the father.
And she came to me and said
that she had thought it
through, and if I really wanted
to do that, she wanted
to do it too.
And so we have a daughter of
whom I am the biological and
actual father.
My daughter, Blaine, who lives
with her mother in Texas, but
comes to visit a lot.
And then I said to John that I
thought it would be really
great for us to have a kid at
home with us full time.
He wasn't as sure of the
idea as I was, but he
came around to it.
And so we then decided
to do that.
Since I was the one who
championed the idea, I was to
be the biological father.
Laura, the lesbian mother of
Oliver and Lucy, then offered
to be our surrogate.
So we have an egg donor and
Laura carried the pregnancy.
And as she was doing that, we
got to be very close to Laura
and Tammy and Oliver and Lucy.
And they announced at some point
that they wanted to call
us Daddy and Papa as little
Blaine in Texas did.
And so we now have by shorthand,
five parents of
four children in three states.
And it's proved to be an
unbelievably joyful
experience.
And I think my sense that you
could have a child who is
different or a childhood that
was different and that it
could still be so rich and
rewarding, very much came out
of this book.
Now, the day that George was
born, there was a knot in the
umbilical cord when
he was born.
And the day after he was born,
the doctor came in and said
he's extending his legs in a
very peculiar fashion, and
we're concerned that there
may be brain damage.
And it was very shocking to me
having written this whole book
about how people find all of
this wonderful meaning in
these experiences of difficulty
to suddenly be
confronted with that idea myself
and to think how much I
didn't want to find that
particular kind of meaning.
And it lasted a couple of hours
and then it turned out
that he was fine, and the whole
thing was over, but it
was a very traumatic
experience.
And I'm just going to close this
talk by reading to you
from the final paragraph
of the book in which I
reflected this idea.
I said, "Children ensnared
me the moment I connected
fatherhood with loss.
But I am not sure I would have
noticed that if I hadn't been
immersed in this research.
Encountering so much strange
love I fell into its
bewitching patterns and saw how
splendor can illuminate
even the most abject
vulnerabilities.
I had witnessed and learned
the terrifying joy of
unbearable responsibility,
recognized how it conquers
everything else.
Sometimes I had thought the
heroic parents in this book
were fools enslaving themselves
to a life's journey
with their alien children,
trying to breed
identity out of misery.
I was startled to learn that
my research had built me a
plank, and that I was ready to
join them on their ship."
Thank you very, very much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'll be glad to take some
questions, and there's a video
that we are apparently not
going to be able to show.
But I think that it will
be available online.
AUDIENCE: We can show it.
ANDREW SOLOMON: Oh,
you can show it.
Oh, fantastic.
You can meet some of
the people I was
just talking about.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-When I was born death,
my mother cried.
She really did not
see a future.
-The doctors said, he would
never amount to anything.
His mental capacity would
be little to none.
And you should probably
give him up
and think about adoption.
-I really didn't even know that
something was going on,
that there was something
wrong in my mind.
-I didn't know the
word transsexual.
The word transgender hadn't
even been invented yet.
-He has a mentor
that helps him.
No biting, Chris.
Chris probably had one of the
worst diagnosis ever-- self
injurious, swollen intestines,
poisons in him system, mental
retardation, severe autism.
And I was pretty much told to
put him in an institution.
-When I was born, my
mom refused to see
me for three days.
She was scared.
-Before I transitioned, I
just wasn't all there.
I couldn't quite share
my feelings.
I couldn't quite be a full
member of the family.
-You sort of get what you get.
And you go from there.
And it's your choice.
You want to make the best of it,
you make the best of it.
You want to make the
worst of it, throw
yourself a pity party.
-I set out to write a book which
was about how people
found meaning in difficulty.
It's hard for the kids
to accept themselves.
It's hard for their families
to accept them.
It's hard for the larger society
to accept the kids and
their parents.
All of it is a struggle.
I wouldn't ever want to pretend
that these aren't
difficult lives.
They are very difficult lives.
They're full of pain
and complexity.
-We have joints and bones that
are twisted and distorted.
So our life is marred with
a lot of surgeries.
Myself, I've had 30.
-And there was one guy that
I had a crush on.
He said to me, why
do you lisp?
And my heart would crush.
-Chris did not communicate.
He didn't sit down.
He didn't put on clothes.
He wouldn't go outside.
He ate the walls.
He ate the table.
He at the rug.
-I could feel the back of my
neck popping and sizzling.
Like my head was just
heating up.
-We couldn't eat in the home.
We couldn't have lights on.
We couldn't have the TV on.
If I coughed, he would run
downstairs and punch me.
-I actually felt that I was a
surgeon, and I felt I had to
literally extricate the demon
from inside of my body.
-When I started this book, I
knew that I was going to be
looking at a lot of desperate
situations.
-And I would do that by cutting
and burning myself.
-What I didn't know was how much
joy I was going to find.
-When I was born, my dad
said, he looks cute.
He's just got a big head
and little arms.
The funny thing is I still
look that way.
-And the relief that came over
my face when I heard that
there was a name to what
was going on with me.
-I used what God gave me.
God didn't give me
legs to run.
He didn't give me arms to
play football with.
He gave me a brain, and He gave
me a heart, and I try to
use both of those things
to the fullest.
-The thing I've learned most
over the years is to be a
parent first.
I thought to myself, if he's
happy, if he stops hurting
himself, if I can hug him, that
would be the greatest
gift in life.
-It's kind of pretty sure that
I'm going to have obstacles,
but I would have had
them anyway.
-I know my dad is very,
very proud of me.
Because I went on a
journey that he
never dreamed possible.
-I don't think of myself
as a schizophrenic.
I am Susan.
-There really isn't any
definition and what's normal,
or not normal, or far from the
tree, or right under the tree.
-I'm lucky to have had her in
this particular period of
time.
-I'm lucky too.
-And thank you.
-The love that parents have
for their children--
-I guess we are pretty
lucky, huh?
-Yes, Mom.
We are.
- --can see them through
an enormous amount.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AUDIENCE: I was just curious in
terms of the parents that
you characterized as heroic
versus the parents, who
without sort of that judgment,
maybe we characterize as less
than heroic.
Did you see any commonalities
between those two groups in
terms of their attitude?
Or what did it take for
parents to be heroic?
Did you see any common things
among those parents?
ANDREW SOLOMON: Well, I should
first of all say that I have a
lot of empathy for parents who
have got children like this
and are not having the easiest
and best time with them.
I think it's a tall order,
and it's tough.
And so I wouldn't want to come
down against the other.
But what I found mostly was this
thing of searching for
meaning and trying to see a way
in which having this child
had forced them to grow
and to change.
So I think it's the issue
really with difficulty
altogether in life, is that you
can either rail against it
and be angry at it, or you can
accept whatever difficulty
can't, in fact, be ameliorated
and just decide that's you're
going to look for a way
to build something
positive out of it so.
When you had the mother of that
dwarf saying our child
had this extraordinary light,
and he did these things.
Or even when you had the mother
who said when she
buried her child that she had
come to love him, it's the
onset, it's the openness to
falling in love with your own
child that I think makes an
enormous difference in the
sense that you've been put on
this path that isn't the one
you would have chosen, but
nonetheless, offers rewards
which are perhaps different
from the rewards you
anticipated.
There's a famous little passage
that was written by
Emily Kingsley who's the mother
of a child with Down
syndrome called "Welcome to
Holland," which I have
reproduced in this book that we
may have to take it out for
the edition published in the
Netherlands, but in which she
says that having children is
like planning a trip to Italy
but having a child like hers is
when they are coming into
land and you're told actually,
you're landing in Holland.
And you have to recognize
that you will never see
Michelangelo's David.
And you will never get to sort
of walk through the forum or
take a Gondola in Venice, but
actually the place you're in
is full of Rembrandts
and tulips.
And if you can learn to
appreciate those other things
instead, no matter how much
you may still regret not
getting to Italy, you can find
a lot of joy in Holland.
And it's a little cutesy, but it
actually, I think, sums up
a lot of the attitude
in question.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You talked about a
couple of quotes about in view
of homosexuality and Down
syndrome back in the '60s and
'70s and how society
has evolved.
What do you think has
contributed to that?
And what do you think will be
your prediction of how things
will be 30 or 40 years from now
in terms of perception and
experience with different
children?
ANDREW SOLOMON: That's an
excellent question.
I think the thing that really
has made for the shift has
been the rights movements.
And I think the rights movements
have come in a wave.
I think the women's movement and
the original civil rights
movement really set the stage
for the gay rights movement
and the disability
rights movement.
And that uncomfortable though
people in some of these groups
may be with people in others of
these groups that actually
it's been a liberalizing
tendency that's taken place
over a long period of time.
You know, met also with a
certain amount of opposition,
but there's been more and more
of a recognition that there is
a diversity of experience that
constitutes human experience.
In terms of where we'll be in 30
or 40 years, I'd be really
curious, because I feel like
where we are now in terms of
gay rights was unimaginable
30 or 40 years ago.
And will we continue to go
in the same direction?
Will more and more ways of being
become acceptable, or
will the medical progress we're
making cause us once
more to narrow the definition
of what it is to be human?
History has gone in waves.
It's unusual for there to be
nothing but steady progress
over a long period of time.
I don't know which of the things
that we now experience
as an illness will in
the end be conceived
primarily as an identity.
What I know is that it will
not all be the same
as it is right now.
So there are things that right
now we think of as totally
bizarre that in 40 years ago
might seem to people to be
perfectly ordinary.
Will polygamy be an ordinary
thing in 40 years?
I don't have any crystal ball
to say what the things are,
but I think there are things
that the standards of sexual
contact between adults and
children, will things that now
seem acceptable become
unacceptable.
Will things that now seem
unacceptable seem more
acceptable?
Will there be more integration
of people with different kinds
of intelligence?
Will autism continue
to increase?
Will the autism rights movement
mean that we more and
more accept that many people
are not neurotypical and we
accept the motor social
interaction that seems to come
most readily to them?
All of it is unclear.
So I don't know what it
will be, but I do
know it will be different.
And where we are is
so different from
where we were before.
And where we're headed
will be different.
And I think I should say that
part of the reason that
everything has changed now, and
there may not be another
radical revision like this, but
is because of the advent
of the internet and the ability,
if I may be allowed
in this context to say so, to
figure out what the quality is
you have and Google it.
All you have to do is to put in
child with multiple severe
disabilities, and you've got
thousands and thousands of
articles and links and means
of meeting other parents.
So a lot of these conditions
people
experienced in terrible isolation.
And now they experience
them in community.
And that shift has
been enormous.
And once you have a community,
you can fight for tolerance.
So that has also been
a gigantic shift.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: My question
sort of comes--
I'm not a parent and I haven't
finished the book yet, but I
love what I've read so far.
ANDREW SOLOMON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I have had a hard
time understanding the choices
some of the parents who
choose to-- kind of,
here was my life before.
And it's all gone and now I
have a child, and my whole
life is involved in taking
care of them.
An example that I use this from
the chapter on autism,
the mother--
Betsy or Betty--
basically had multiple
depressive episodes that
caused her to be hospitalized.
Her husband had bipolar
disorder and was also
hospitalized.
And I think they actually put a
child into a care facility.
But I wonder if you could--
if you don't mind explaining as
much as you can maybe, the
choices that the parents
go through.
I still have a hard time
understanding how people get
rid of their old life and
get self-directed again.
I wake up and have breakfast in
the morning versus oh, what
does my child want.
Again, I'm not a parent so maybe
it changes no matter
what anyway.
But I just wonder how
do they do that?
And how does it make sense?
And how are they crazy?
ANDREW SOLOMON: Well, some
of them are crazy.
As you observed, the particular
family you're
talking about all ended up in
intensive psychiatric care.
A lot of the time, it's not
something that people have
thought through before
they have children.
And then you have children with
these kinds of special
needs, and they really require
you to make this radical shift
in your way of life partly just
because of the actual
physical demands on your time.
So especially for people who
don't have enormous economic
resources and can't outsource
a lot of the early care, you
have a child who's
got a disability.
The child is being
operated on.
You're stuck in the hospital.
You're stuck going
back and forth.
You take the child home.
He requires 24-hour care.
I mean, a lot of them don't sit
and make the decision, I
will nobly and heroically give
up my life in favor of this
other way of being.
But rather simply--
[VIDEO PLAYING]
ANDREW SOLOMON: Well,
there's the--
[VIDEO PLAYING]
ANDREW SOLOMON: OK.
If we could get the picture,
that would be great.
[VIDEO PLAYING]
ANDREW SOLOMON: Yes.
Where were we?
So making the huge sacrifices,
I think it's really a process
in which people are dragged
kicking and screaming.
And then they make sense of
it a little bit later on.
That's really how it begins.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In the introduction
you talked a little bit about
some of the identities you
thought you might discuss in
the book that were
not included.
And I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about
the process and how far you went
in your research and then
why you decided not
to pursue those.
And whether those may become
magazine articles later or a
second book.
I don't know.
ANDREW SOLOMON: Someone just
actually asked me, they want
to do a sort of little limited
edition book with some of
those stories in it.
I started off looking at dozens
and dozens of topics.
And I narrowed them down--
partly, I chose the ones in
which people had in which
I heard amazing stories.
And so some of them
came really out of
the narrative content.
But I also felt that if I was
talking about deafness, even
though blindness is very
different, I didn't really
need to blindness because
the issues were similar.
And if I was doing dwarfism,
I didn't really need to do
gigantism because a lot of the
underlying issues-- even if
the medical issues were actually
quite different-- a
lot of the underlying issues
were the same.
There was a lot of doing that
kind of elimination and then
there was a certain amount of
just slashing things because
it's quite a chunky
book as it is.
And I was worried that if I
tried to make it any longer,
it would become unwieldy
and unreadable.
So there were some that just
went for that reason.
But there were so many amazing
stories that I heard even in
these other areas.
And the idea of giving them
up, it was difficult.
It came at a cost.
I gave up individual families
within each of the chapters,
and I also gave up
whole chapters.
But I wanted to cover
a spectrum.
And I felt that if we started
with deafness, which is
probably the most readily
accepted as an identity and
which is in some ways for people
who grow up using sign
fluently, the one that has the
least long term, obvious
detriment in their lives.
We started with the deafness
and dwarfism really.
And then we went on to
these other things.
And if we looked at the
ones that are disease
constructions, which is the
first half of the book, and
the ones that are more identity
constructions, which
are the second half, I
hoped I was being as
representative as possible.
Yeah.
In the back.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious when you
set out to write the book, and
you talked a little bit about
it, you touched on it here
some of it in an initial
publication.
But was this a bit of like a
parental litmus test for you?
Were you sort of looking for a
reason not to be a parent?
I mean, I don't mean to sound
simplistic, but was it a way
to talk yourself out of it?
ANDREW SOLOMON: It was certainly
not a way to talk
myself out of being a parent.
I wanted to be a parent.
I'd always wanted
to be a parent.
And I had at various stages
struggled with the issue of
being gay mostly because I
thought it would prevent me
from being a parent.
So that had been
kind of steady.
When I realized I could be a
parent, of course, I then went
into a panic mode, but that
was a little later on.
But I think that it was a means
of looking squarely at
what parenthood entailed and
realizing that it was doable.
So I think in a way,
it was the reverse.
It was a way of saying, I'm
terribly anxious about how I
would deal with having a child
who's different in some way.
I know that I am a child who
was different in some way.
I know that it was hard for my
parents, though we all got
through it and came out
happily in the end.
You know, would I be able to do
it and how can I learn how
to do it in case I have a child
who presents what are,
for me, challenges like
the ones that I
posed for my own parents.
And it was really kind
of the focus.
So yeah.
But I mean, I don't think I
realized that I was writing it
until well into it.
AUDIENCE: But I was wondering
if your parents are still
alive, and if so, how they
responded to the book and how
that journey has
been for them.
ANDREW SOLOMON: My mother died
22 years ago, but my father is
still alive, and he's been
immensely supportive of the
book all the way through.
He read all of the
drafts and so on.
He's been a big supporter.
I think there were things in it
that were difficult, but he
said that he felt like
ultimately it expressed a real
truth about ways in which we
had all struggled and how
we've made it through.
So it had a very good
response to it.
Thanks.
Yeah, yes?
AUDIENCE: My question
is a kind of
writing process question.
Was there a moment or was there
sort of a process where
you committed to the fact that
this was going to just be like
a huge endeavor and one single
thing rather than a collection
of articles about identity
politics that were sort of
different outlooks?
ANDREW SOLOMON: So I was always
clear that I wanted to
keep it as one book.
There was discussion about
whether it should be broken
into two books, and I felt like,
well, I have insights
within each chapter, the primary
insight is the uniting
insight, and if we broke it
up, that would get lost.
And that was the problem.
And the complexity--
actually, I'm now looking at
the possibility of making a
documentary film--
is how do you sort of squash all
of this into 90 minutes or
something like that and not
have it become completely
incoherent.
I don't think I understood
the extent to it.
I mean, I saw it as a book that
was going to take me 3
years and it took me 11.
So it became clear as I went
along that for me to feel like
I could really speak with
authority on these topics, I
had to learn a huge amount.
I was thinking, if a book
expresses more than 10% of
what you know about the thing
you're writing about, it's not
going to be a very
convincing book.
And I think if I understood how
huge it was going to be, I
would never have
undertaken it.
But then once I was in the
middle, it was a little like
the Vietnam War.
I sort of thought I put
in so much already, I
have to keep going.
So that was kind of
the feeling of it.
Yeah.
Anyone else?
OK.
Well, thank you all so much
for coming to this in the
middle of your busy day.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]